- Hi, I'm Rie.
Welcome back to "Make it Fancy".
Before we begin, we got
some cool new merch.
You can check it out
at shopmakeitfancy.com.
Let's see what I'm making fancy today.
- Hey Rie, it's Katie and
today I'm challenging you
to make rice crispy treats fancy.
I used to eat these all
the time growing up.
I'd have 'em after soccer games.
They definitely remind me of being young.
I would love to see you
make them more fancy
and kind of elevate them.
So I can't wait to see
how you make it fancy.
- Rice Krispies Treats.
This is a limited Make it Fancy edition.
It's only existing here.
It's so cute.
Rice crispy with marshmallow,
it's a little too sweet for me.
Oh. It's not bad.
I like the texture.
It's gooey, but it's still crispy.
This is better than I expected.
As always, I'm excited to make it fancy.
All right. Here's what I got.
Marshmallows, sprinkles,
strawberry chocolate,
white chocolate, milk chocolate,
cocoa powder, cacao nibs,
butter, cream cheese, and heavy cream.
From the pantry I got
canola oil, coconut oil,
vanilla extract, salt, food
coloring, and powdered sugar.
Let's get started.
Make it fancy.
I have three cups of heavy cream
heated up just on the boil.
It's nice and hot.
Add rice crispy treats.
Simmer this about 15 minutes and reduce it
to one and a half cup.
15 minutes later.
- [Producer] Rie, we have another
special rice crispy treats package.
- Throw them.
- [Producer] Yeah, sure.
- Oh, it's so cute.
Me.
Strain it. Put this in a
refrigerator at least one hour.
So it get very cold.
I have six inch cake bun.
Spray oil so it doesn't stick.
And I have rice crispy treats,
process this in the food processor.
Woohoo.
Looks nice.
Set this aside.
Move on to next step.
Four tablespoon of butter, melt it.
One cup of mini marshmallow,
melt this completely.
This marshmallow gave me a flashback
of our marshmallow episode.
Our producer Cyrus told me
alligator likes marshmallows,
but alligator is almost
like a dinosaur, right?
Alligator was there before
marshmallow was invented
who did it to them?
So this is completely melted.
Add cocoa powder, one table spoon.
I like using cocoa powder
and of course, cocoa nibs
so we can kind of balance
it out, the sweetness.
Crushed rice crispy, two
table spoon of cacao nibs,
mix it.
I think it looks very appetizing.
It's gooey and chocolate-y.
I want to make sure
everything is evenly coated.
It looks great.
You put this in a pan.
This might be a little hot
so I'm gonna start with the spatula.
You press to the mold
and cover the bottom part
then you want to make it even thickness.
I'm going to put this in
the freezer about 15 minutes
so it firm up.
I have one half cup
chilled rice crispy treats
infused heavy cream.
I'm going to whip this by hand.
I saw "America's Test kitchen".
The fastest way to whip cream
by hand was just doing this.
I feel like my arm get tired
so I kind of want to move around.
All right. This is looking good.
I got the medium stiff peaks.
I'm going to chill this.
One pound cream cheese,
put it in the stand mixer.
Half cup of powdered sugar.
And using paddle attachment,
mix it until smooth.
I'm gonna scrape the side.
Half tablespoon of vanilla extract,
quarter teaspoon of salt.
All right. This looks nice.
So I have this cream cheese mixture here
combine one and half
cup rice crispy treats
infused whipped cream.
I like the texture.
Jiggle jiggle.
Using spatula, fold that in.
I think it's gonna be delicious.
- [Producer] Rie, are you
familiar with the elf trio?
- Do they have name?
- [Producer] One is named
Snap, one is named Crackle.
- Another one is Gooey.
- [Producer] Pop.
- Pop.
Elf is always look like a grandpa, right?
And I'm going to divide
this mixture into three.
I still have a little
bit whipped cream left,
but I'm going to use it for
later and let's get fancy.
(piano playing)
I melted three different chocolate,
milk chocolate, white chocolate,
and strawberry chocolate.
And now I'm going to mix into
the cream cheese mixture.
First, I'm going to mix
with milk chocolate.
Mix well, looks good.
Pour this into the mold with crust.
Use small offset spatula,
smooth the surface.
Freeze this about five minutes.
This one was in freezer and it it's firm.
Next layer, white chocolate.
Again, using offset spatula
and making even layer.
All right. It looks great.
Put this in the freezer for five minutes.
So it's firmed up, make the third layer.
And I'm going to add a
little bit of food coloring
because when you mix with
cream cheese and strawberry
it's get very pale.
So I just want to make
a little bit vibrant.
The strawberry chocolate, it's popular
'cause like there's
Pocky strawberry flavor.
It's similar to Neapolitan.
It has chocolate and white and strawberry.
Okay using offset spatula.
Pan is getting heavy. It's very full.
Refrigerate this at least six hours.
I have two parchment paper.
Put rice crispy and using
rolling pin you just roll it.
You want to roll maybe
like half the thickness.
- [Producer] In 2015, somebody made
the world's biggest rice krispies treat.
Guess the weight.
- 250 pounds.
- [Producer] 11,327 pounds.
- That's so off.
I have a strawberry shaped cookie cutter.
It's very sticky.
So I'm going to use this, the plunger.
So I am making strawberry
shaped rice crispy treats.
I think Katie will like it.
I think Katie likes cute stuff.
I'm going to make more and
I'm excited to show Katie
what the final product look like.
I have all rice crispy treats strawberry
and I'm going to cover with
melted strawberry chocolate
with coconut oil.
And I'm going to freeze
this for five minutes.
Chocolate is set.
But it doesn't look like strawberry,
so I'm going to make it
look more like strawberry.
And this is just a melted white chocolate.
Make a tiny dots.
White chocolate is a little bit sticky
and it's kind of giving me a streak
so I try not to move too much
to make it perfect strawberry seeds
and twisting the toothpick so
it doesn't have any streak.
My hands used to be very shaky,
but now I feel like I
gained a steady hands.
Chill this and get ready to decorate.
So I go inspired from Korean lunchbox cake
and I have this like paper lunchbox.
Put pink tissue.
I'm using offset spatula to unmold it.
All right. And I'm going
to decorate the cake
with strawberry shaped rice crispy treats.
And I have some pastel color sprinkles.
Rice crispy treats infused whipped cream.
This is actually inspired
by the baker in San Jose.
Her name is Tina Lee.
Her cake was really pretty.
I'm piping with star piping tip.
I'm adding my final touches
and make a strawberry top
with white chocolate.
And I'm going to use toothpick
to make little strawberry top decoration.
And we are done.
(gentle music)
Rice crispy treats lunchbox cake.
Very cute and fancy.
Hey, I like your tee shirt.
- I got this shirt from
shopmakeitfancy.com.
So can you.
- I want to surprise you.
- I'm so excited.
- so I'm kind of covering.
(Katie gasps)
- Oh my good. Wait, Rie you made this?
- This is so cute, right?
- [Katie] This is gorgeous.
- Thank you. I said you really like it.
When I think of you like a pastel
- Yes. I love pastel.
- [Rie] color, somehow.
- Well, I also just love desserts
that just look like almost
like an art project.
- Do you know like Korean lunchbox cake?
- Okay. That's what this is based off of.
- Yes.
- This is so pretty though.
- Thank you.
- This is better
than anyone I've seen online.
This is so good.
Oh, you've got four different layers here.
- Yes.
- Do you wanna eat it?
- Yeah. Well, yeah.
- Yes.
- Definitely. A hundred percent yes.
Should you do the honors, Rie?
- Like a wedding?
- Like a wedding? Oh my God.
Do we do it together?
- [Producer] Do it together.
- It's so romantic.
(Rie and Katie humming)
- [Katie] So this is like, you'd give this
as a gift to somebody
- [Rie] Yeah.
- for their birthday.
Commit. Commit.
Yay. Oh, beautiful.
- Okay. Are we sharing?
- Yeah, let's just share.
- Okay. Let's just share.
- That was such a labor
intensive reply from me.
Ooh. Okay.
It does have a kind of a fudgey
texture at the bottom here.
Okay.
- [Both] Cheers.
- Mm.
So good.
Did you infuse the cream with?
It tastes like, like rice crispies.
- Yes.
- Like you get
that marshmallowy flavor
- Yeah.
- in it and it's very fluffy.
It's so good.
- Mm-hmm.
- Okay, wait. I gotta try this strawberry.
Oh, that was infused too?
- Mm-hmm.
- Mm. That's so good, Rie.
- Yay. Thank you.
♪ Rie made rice crispies fancy. ♪
Oh, yes.
Three, two, one.
- [Both] Make it fancy.
(bright music)